well Nancy Pelosi has caused some
consternation on the left because she's
she said in a Washington Post interview
that she does not now favor impeaching
Trump she said I'm not for impeachment
this is news I haven't said this to any
press person before but since you asked
and I've been thinking about this
impeachment is so divisive to this
country that unless there's something so
compelling and overwhelming and
bipartisan I don't think we should go
down that path because it divides the
country and he's just not worth it now
she did though try to retain her
resistance credentials by then going on
to talk about how Trump is
intellectually and ethically unfit for
office which even you know we're so used
to hearing that kind of thing but even a
statement like that which is so common
from Democrats about Trump where they
talk about how he's unfit for office but
as recently as the Obama administration
for Republicans to say that he was unfit
can you imagine a Republican saying that
Obama was intellectually unfit for
office that would have been a huge
scandal and and there there may have
been a few Republicans or a few some
conservatives who said Obama was unfit
for office but that kind of language was
considered a big deal it was like ooh
you know but now this is just Democrats
just they just just it's just normal
it's just what they say he's he's unfit
for office he's he's scum music he's
awful ilhan omar said yesterday that
Trump is not even human and and yet
again that's just you know that's that's
where our rhetoric is know that that's
where that's where that's the state of
political discourse is where that's
completely normal but she does think
anyway Pelosi says that impeachment
isn't a good idea now think about this
for a minute think about where we are
that first of all it took Nancy Pelosi
two years to say that she doesn't want
to impeach even though that there were
even though there was never any reason
to impeach it took her two years to say
let's not add peach and also that this
news
a shock to other Democrats who really
want impeachment though again they have
no basis for it they have no reason they
just want it and I've been saying all
along that that's going to be the last
straw for our democracy the last straw
will be when an oppositional party tries
officially to remove a sitting president
simply because they don't like him and
they're opposed to his politics now the
Democrats don't really have the power to
do that that's the other thing there's
to impeach the president wouldn't
accomplish anything because the
impeachment is just sort of like an
indictment in order for there to be a
trial and actually remove him from
office you need I believe 2/3 of the
Senate and of course they don't have
anywhere close to 2/3 of the Senate to
make that happen so they don't have the
power to do it and that's part of the
reason why no president has ever been
successfully some presidents have been
impeached but no president's been
successfully removed from office because
it would require such an overwhelming
amount of support in the legislative
branch that it is very difficult to do
so that protects us and it turns out
that our founding fathers were pretty
smart dudes you know in the end they
they set it up so that you would
probably need a really really good
reason legitimate reason to actually
remove a president now if it's a if it
was impossible to remove a president
then we would have tyranny but if it's
too easy then you're gonna have
presidents getting kicked out left and
right and then you have a banana
republic so we don't have that but I
think we're moving in that direction we
haven't we haven't crossed that line yet
because of the way that the system is
set up our system prevents it but the
fact that the idea of impeachment was
entertained for so long without reason
without cause is pretty frightening all
right so enough
that was four minutes of politics and
we'll move on already because I think
this is a more important more
interesting topic a man in Alabama by
the name of Ryan majors has been granted
the right to sue an abortion clinic on
behalf of his unborn child who was
aborted by his girlfriend against his
wishes
now this this case as you can imagine
has not been received well to put it
lightly
by by the pro-abortion side I just saw
an article in the independent that was
caught as calling this case terrifying
this is a terrifying case it's
terrifying that a father can seek
justice on behalf of his murdered child
terrifying if you're a child killer or
an apologist for child killers now this
case is is it's important and it's being
called unprecedented because it gives
legal rights to an unborn baby and that
is of course enormous ly consequential
in a very good way but I think it's also
extremely important because by extension
it's giving voice to the father it's
giving voice to the man as well as the
child it there in in an abortion there
are three people involved there are
three people who are profoundly affected
that would be the mother the father and
the child of course but as our law
stands right now although there are
three people involved only one person
has any say or any rights and that would
be the mother so this case gives a voice
to the other two people involved and in
fact I want to I'm gonna play a quick
clip of a local news report featuring
this father because I just want you to
see in his own words I think it's pretty
powerful and this is this is him talking
about the situation in his own words
every time a woman goes to the Alabama
Women's Center with the intent of
getting an abortion she gets this
pamphlet and that's where the suit
alleges that Brian majors girlfriend did
receive her abortion and in this
pamphlet as she had to flipped through
it if she did get this abortion at this
clinic it even shows the different
sizes of the baby at different points in
the pregnancy and and for Ryan to know
that right here around the 6-week Mart
according to that suit that's when his
girlfriend did get that abortion he says
even at this point it's still a decision
he can't seem to wrap his head around
I'm here for the men who actually want
to have their baby it's been nearly two
years since Ryan majors girlfriend
aborted their baby it was just like my
whole world just fell apart and today he
lives with a constant reminder of what
could have been right here in the first
rows I have a due date and it's just
when the baby was supposed to be born
majors 4 out of the lawsuit in Madison
County Wednesday suing Alabama Women's
Center their employees and the
pharmaceutical company who makes the
medication used in an abortion I believe
that every child from conceptionist is a
baby in it deserves to live I talked to
Dalton Johnson who owns the Alabama
Women's Center he wasn't aware of the
suit had been filed but did offer some
insight into abortion procedures the
suit says the baby was aborted at six
weeks Johnson said at that point in the
pregnancy a woman can choose how she
wants to end the pregnancy either by
medication or surgery I just try to play
with her and play with her and just talk
to her about it and see what I could do
but in the end there's nothing I could
do to change your mind
and even though it's too late for majors
to stop his girlfriend's abortion he
said he wants to give a voice to other
would-be dads who find themselves in the
same spot even though there's nothing I
can do for for the situation that I was
in there is something I can do for the
future situations for other people so I
think he's a hero what he's doing is is
heroic and you see here what is perhaps
the most forbidden subject in in public
discourse today the most taboo thing to
bring up and that is the play
of men who whose children are aborted
against their wishes
these are silent victims who we aren't
allowed to talk about but the fact is
that this man Ryan is not an aberration
he is not alone there are many men like
him there are many men who are victims
of abortions themselves because their
children are killed without their
consent it's true that the opposite also
happens quite a bit right there are
plenty of situations where you've got
cowardly weak pathetic disgusting men
who pressure their girlfriends to get
abortions and that does happen we hear
about that sort of thing all the time
but then there's also this what about
the men who are pleading the other way
who begged the mother of their children
not to do it can you imagine just try to
put yourself in the shoes of this man
for a minute can you imagine you
conceive a child and you're excited to
be a father and
mother and child says I'm gonna kill the
baby and there's nothing you can do
about it you cannot stop me can you
imagine being in that position it's it's
impossible to even conceive of course
pro-abortion people are panicking over
this like I said claiming that this is
all about you know this is all about
controlling women's bodies so Jessica
Valenti who's an especially violent
feminist and a sociopath was ranting
about this case on Twitter predictably
saying that this is her word she said
that this isn't about this isn't about
anything other than controlling women's
bodies and then she added that she she
also hates Ryan's face she hates his
face she said because she is as I said
hateful and vile there's just there
aren't enough bad things you could say
about the woman but of course this is
not about controlling women's bodies and
what does it say about pro-abortion
people that they can't conceive of any
other reason why a man might not want
his child to be killed like they
literally can't understand that a father
might actually just not want his child
to be killed not because it's part of
any patriarchal conspiracy to control
women but maybe a father really just
loves his child and doesn't want the
child to be killed they can't understand
that they actually don't understand it
they say what do mean loving you love
your child what does that I don't know
nobody does that they can't understand
it they think no no if a man doesn't
want its kid to be killed it could only
be be because there must be some some
dastardly motivation behind it because
these people are so empty and soulless
inside that they they can't understand
the concept of loving an unborn child
they don't even they don't think it's
possible yet the fact remains that this
baby
is not the woman's body
okay is this is not about controlling
the woman's body because the thing that
is at stake here is not the woman's body
but in fact the body of an entirely
separate person who is the baby and that
person is 50% the result of the woman
and 50% the result of the man that pay
that that other human that third party
involved would not exist without the man
so that child is not the woman's body
and that child does not belong to the
woman that child belongs first of all to
God but in terms of in earthly terms
that child belongs just as much to the
father as he does to the to the mother
the you know what it's not even like 50
150 it's not even that it is 50/50 or
maybe better yet a hundred percent a
hundred percent that that child that's
the better way of putting it that child
is 100 percent the son of this father
and a hundred percent the son of the
mother as well
think about the mixed messages that we
send here with with these sorts of
situations where the message from the
left and by extension from our culture
is what we say to men is when the babies
in the womb we say that's none of your
business none of your concern
you have no vested interest in this you
have no say you have no rights it
doesn't matter what you want if she
wants to keep the baby she's gonna keep
the baby she wants to kill the baby
she's gonna kill a baby in your opinion
does not matter and that's the message
for nine months that's what we say to
men your opinion doesn't matter you have
no interest in this it's not your child
it doesn't matter
mind your business over and over and
over again that's what we say for nine
months and then the moment that child
emerges from the birth canal then we
flip it around and say where's child
support you need to be here don't be a
deadbeat where did you go you need to be
here
taking care of this child now of course
I agree that when the child is born that
the father needs to be there and
shouldn't be a deadbeat and everything
but it's a mixed message in one sense if
the father that's a deadbeat and goes
off and doesn't want to take care of his
child well he's just I guess all he's
doing is he took you seriously when you
said it's not his that's none of his
concern and the father said okay well I
guess not then all right well fine but
even someone like Jessica Valenti I
don't know if she has any kids but you
know I'm sure I'm sure if she had a kid
she would be right oh the father needs
to be here taking care of this kid yeah
you say that now what about before what
if I take you up on your what if I
actually take all of your blathering
seriously about how this is just your
body well hey there was there's no baby
at all it's just your body so I guess
when the baby comes out that's like your
that's your organ or your limb that is
some suddenly come to life and but it's
still yours not mine
no we that's not it that's not fair to
the men that's not fair to the baby it's
just it doesn't make any sense
that child there needs to be a
consistent message to men and the
message is from the very beginning from
conception this is your child and you
need to be here for the child and and
not just when the child is born by the
way but for in the very beginning the
mother of your child is pregnant you
need to be you therefore you need to be
supporting her you need to be interested
you need to be all these and take her to
doctors appointments I mean be involved
get married to her if you're not yet by
the way that should be the message see
that's a message that that works for
everybody you notice that that message
works for everyone works for the child
it works for the mother works for the
father
everybody is built up everybody is
lifted up everyone is putting it put
into a safer and better situation when
that's our message from
but when we try to say that I don't know
you know you need to wait nine months
for your fatherly instinct to set in and
up until that point this is none of your
business well once you start doing that
well you can't do it and what's going to
happen is you know sort of you're gonna
have one principal that's extended in
one direction either way so if the
principle that we're telling the fathers
when the child is in the womb if what
we're telling them is this is none of
your business not your child don't worry
about it get a mind your business
then in many cases that principle is
going to be extended beyond the womb but
if you go the other way and you say no
this is your business this is your child
this is 100% your responsibility just
till it gets a hundred percent the
woman's responsibility then that
principle will also be extended it's
it's a you know it's an interesting
thing that the the pro-life message has
this effect right of lifting people up
and just making
everyone's life better protecting life
treasuring life I mean that's that's the
it's pro life and that's why the the
moniker of pro-choice doesn't mean
anything because these people aren't
about choice even they're not about joy
pro-choice people are manifestly opposed
to choice and freedom in so many when it
comes to so many other issues but even
when it comes to abortion well they're
only they're only concerned about the
choice of one person again there are
three people involved they only care
about the choice of one person and
that's the mother and even then they
only care about the choice if she's
choosing to abort but if she chooses to
keep the baby well then Planned
Parenthood's got nothing for Planned
Parenthood doesn't care
Planned Parenthood says get out of here
if you're not gonna kill a baby we don't
care you go somewhere else we're not
gonna help you so they care about the
choice of one person and as long as it's
only one particular choice but the
father has no choice the baby has no
choice so pro-choice means nothing
pro-life actually means something though
in that people who are really pro-life
they it really means that they just they
are in favor of they think life is a
beautiful thing and it should be
treasured and protected and I mean how
can you disagree how can you be a living
human being and disagree with that all
right so on a related note but on the
opposite end of the spectrum on the
opposite end of the Fatherhood spectrum
I wanted to mention this cuz I saw this
yesterday and you see this kind of thing
these days somewhat frequently there was
a guy a a verified account on Twitter an
author of some kind I think who took to
Twitter yesterday to complain that
Parenthood is really hard really trying
very difficult and he said publicly that
he regrets ever having his son okay so
this is we just talked about Ryan majors
this is like the opposite of Ryan majors
that was a man who wanted to be a father
and this is someone who doesn't so he
said this guy
he said he loves his son loves his son
but he regrets having him says his wife
feels the same way I don't know if
that's true or not but that's what he
said now I'm not gonna put this guy's
name out there because this isn't about
siccing the mob on him that's not the
point I just point to it because it's
part of a trend that you find online and
it seems every few months that there's
something like this it was it was a
couple of months ago we talked about on
the show there was a Hollywood director
someone who went online and said the
same thing expressed regrets about ever
having a child and there have been
articles about this and so on in the
media except every few months you see
this some article about parents who
regret having their kids or I remember
and I remember this well because it was
right around the time when we were
having our twins was about five years
ago and there was a big article in one
of the publications written by a father
who the him and his wife had had twins
through IVF and his life was just so
miserable and so terrible and Wow Wow
and he was whining about it and talking
about how much he regretted having these
these twins so I remember that well
because that was right before we had
twins ourselves so you see this kind of
thing right this is a sentiment that
people feel apparently increasingly
comfortable expressing publicly and
there are a couple of points that come
to mind when I see this and when I read
this guy's tweets in particular first of
all he says he loves his child
the
I love my child I love my son but I wish
he was never born
well okay then you don't love your child
and this is something that people do
where we we think of
parent loving their child as this sort
of automatic thing and so we assume that
well everyone loves a child and so even
if someone says hey I love my child I
wish that he didn't exist but I of
course I of course I love him well then
by definition you don't love him
sometimes you hear the same thing from
women who abort their child so I love my
child but it just wasn't the right time
no you didn't love them that is the
opposite of loving them so know this guy
you do not love you you clearly do not
love him if you ever find yourself
wishing that a person didn't it's not
even this in in some ways this is even
worse than wishing that someone was dead
as horrible as that is as horrible as
horrible as it is to even conceive of
someone wishing that their child was
dead when someone regrets being a parent
well what you wish is that you're that
this person your child never existed you
you want to negate you wish that you
could negate their entire existence so
that's not love second thing is let's be
clear about this
it is 100% about weakness and
selfishness on the part of this man and
his wife to if if she really does feel
the same way and that is only that is
only highlighted by the fact that he has
one child okay you have one you've got
two adults versus one child now look
there could be extenuating circumstances
sometimes that make it especially
difficult or challenging to have one kid
if there's severe medical problems or
some other situation that can make that
difficult but he didn't mention anything
like that so it seems like this is just
a normal situation in a normal situation
with a healthy child one kid is really
not difficult at all
what are you doing whining about it but
of one of your parents I just have one
kid you hear this a lot though
constantly talk about difficult it is
how difficult I mean come there are
challenges involved in it I know but you
got two parents versus one kid how could
you possibly how overwhelming could have
possibly took the two of you and one of
him how bad could it ever be if you're
feeling that overwhelmed by one kid it
just me this is all that means it just
means that you are completely unwilling
to make even the slightest adjustments
to your life because with one kid you're
gonna have to make some sacrifices you
got to make some adjustments but not
even the adjustments you make what don't
even have to be that serious with one
kid you could basically continue living
your life almost like you did before you
could still go out pretty much whenever
you want just get a babysitter or
anything to get a babysitter for one kid
is not that expensive you've got you
know one parent or the other could
always go out and get time to themselves
and the other parent can watch the one
kid you can bring one kid with you
pretty much anywhere and and you know
it's not if you've taken to a restaurant
if the kid gets a little bit rowdy or
something you got one of the parents can
take him out for a minute but when it's
just one kid you can do these things
it's when you start getting more kids
that then all of a sudden you really are
changing your lifestyle considerably so
this is what jumped outta me is that if
you're feeling this way with one kid
that just means that you you are not
willing to make any sacrifices you don't
want to change your life at all
that's how selfish you are
and yes Parenthood will be an awful
terrible miserable thing if you are
totally unwilling to sacrifice but if
you can just get over the fact that
you're gonna have to make some
adjustments in your life if you can
accept that and move on and accept the
parameters of your new life well then
there's a whole lot of joy to be
discovered but sadly there are many
parents who
can't do that because they are so so
selfish and weak you talk to adults
sometimes in fact I was talking to
someone someone recently about this very
subject and they told me that their own
parents this was an adult they told me
their own parents would tell them as
they were growing up that they the
parents wish that this person had never
been born and you hear that sometimes
you know adults who grew up with this
with parents who wish that they didn't
exist
I mean think about how weak and just
selfish and narcissistic you have to be
especially if at no point you listen I
remember when our when our twins were
born we had now I we never had the
experience of having one kid because we
went right to twins and and when our
twins were born I can I can distinctly
remember that first night with the kids
with us and that was really overwhelming
that was like that was a moment of what
did we just do but very quickly even
when it's a such a huge change when you
go from you know a family with no kids
to two right away very quickly I think
for most people you just even though
it's very challenging challenging to
have to have a newborn itand and by the
way when I'm talking about how easy it
is to have one kid i with the exception
of the newborn stage the newborn stage
just doesn't matter how many kids want
one newborn because of the sleeping
factor if you if you're new board isn't
sleeping for six months well even if it
is just one that's gonna be really that
is really hard but that doesn't last
forever you know you get over that get
past that stage pretty quickly but and
even though it's
very challenging the newborn newborn
stage specifically because of the
sleeping thing I mean you're not getting
sleep that has an effect on you
psychologically there's no question
about it but even then you quickly
accept right for most people you accept
will this okay this is this is what my
life is now this is my new existence and
any thought of I wish it wasn't like
this or why did we do this I mean that
all that stuff just kind of evaporates
it doesn't mean anything anymore because
this is simply your life wherever you go
there you are right this is your life
but then there are parents who I think
for most parents you accept your new
existence very quickly like within days
but then there are some parents who
never do they go years and they can
never accept it and that is nothing but
selfishness and weakness and that's what
we should call it I don't want to hear
any of this well we have to be
understanding of them and you know let's
be sympathetic today now I'm not
sympathetic to them at all stop being
weak you coward
be a man man up get over yourself really
all right I want to get to some email so
you can always email the show Matt wall
show at gmail.com at well show gmail.com
alright I think we're gonna do just one
email in the interest of time here let
me see if I can find the one that was
interesting okay this is from Joanna she
says hi Matt I'm getting caught up on
all your podcast went back to the
beginning and have been listening to
most of them I just listened to your
podcast on the Flat Earth theory those
are from a few few months ago have you
seen the documentary behind the curve
it's all about the Flat Earth theory and
its proponents I found it very
fascinating I was wondering if you've
heard of it
/ seen it well I hadn't heard of it or
seen it I got this email over the
weekend and I hadn't heard of it or seen
a Johanna until I read this email and I
was in a hotel I was on the road over
the weekend and looking for something to
watch so I took this suggestion and I
watched this documentary about the Flat
Earth theorists and if you want to go
watch it behind the curve is what it's
called
my god it was really like gawking at a
car wreck in fact it was like gawking at
people who are gawking at a car wreck
and arguing about whether or not an
alien caused it that's that's what it
was like it was disturbing darkly
hilarious very interesting but it made
my faith in humanity plummet to an
all-time low and it was never that high
to begin with so if you haven't seen it
this movie behind the curve it's it's
about the Flat Earth theorists who we
can't even really call theorists right
the Flat Earth theory is not really a
theory because for something to be a
theory as a scientist in the documentary
explained something has to if something
is a theory it needs to be falsifiable
and not already falsified and then I
would add a third criterium that it
needs to have explanatory power meaning
it has to sufficiently explain what we
see occurring around us in order for it
to really be a theory but Flat Earth the
Flat Earth thing has already been
falsified for thousands of years and
thus it is no longer falsifiable like if
you're going to reject the thousands of
different falsifications of this insane
idea and invent out of whole cloth these
cinematic conspiracies that explain
everything away that you see well then
it's graduated to something that is both
falsified and unfalsifiable which is
piec crazy when you've got something
that's already been falsified but it
also can no longer be falsified anymore
because of this fortification of
conspiracy theory that you've erected
well that that's just that's as crazy as
it gets and then also the Flat Earth
theory has no explanatory power because
for instance it can't even explain
something as simple as well when
astronauts go into space they can orbit
the earth in the International Space
Station and see the globe so you're
flattered thirty fighter theory has to
be able to explain that and just saying
oh no they're lying it's a conspiracy
that's not an explanation to reject
reality is not a good explanation for
reality
but I thought what made the documentary
fascinating especially is just to see
how these people get sucked into this
crazy belief how they justify to
themselves and then this is to me was
the most interesting part it shows how
the flat earthers are so addicted to
conspiracy theories that they end up
separating into factions and like
denominations and then coming up with
conspiracy theories about each other so
there's a there was a a certain
prominent flat earther this kind of the
the spokeswoman for Flat Earth theory
apparently and other flat earthers have
come up with a conspiracy theory that
she is a CIA agent working for Warner
Brothers for some reason or something
like that and this is just what they
they they love conspiracy theory so much
they just can't help it they make it
about each other there was an
interesting moment in the documentary
where that woman and forget it I think
is Patricia was her name she was talking
about these conspiracy theories that
people have about her including there
are some people who think that she's a
reptilian alien creature by the way
shapeshifter and she was saying she
there was just that there was this brief
moment where you can see this glimmer of
light there's there was this moment of
recognition very briefly where she said
she said I don't know these people come
up with crazy conspiracies conspiracy
theories about me is that what I'm doing
am I like them and then she quickly
shook shook that office I don't know I'm
different I'm totally different but
there was that moment oh it almost
dawned our honor almost very interesting
and the other thing I think that it
shows is how people invent and maintain
these conspiracy theories and also why
they do so psychologically and so it's
it's interesting I would go and it's
it's I think as a psychological portrait
of conspiracy theorists it's worth
watching and the main thing you see
about how conspiracy theories operate is
and you've probably already noticed this
from other conspiracy theories but all
they need is just one allegedly
unexplained detail just one and they can
they can build an entire mythology out
of that one tiny little gap in the
official narrative even if it's not
really a gap so for instance the 9/11
truthers the big thing for them
especially early on was well jet fuel
doesn't burn hot enough to melt steel
and then that was all they needed they
were off to the races and of course you
say well but yes it would be it burns
hot enough to weaken steel and then it
collapses under its own weight but by
the time you've already offered that
correction they're way over there
there's no getting them back so with
flat earthers they have a couple little
things like that where they say oh yeah
well then what what about this and it's
always something like well if I stand
really far away from a city I can still
see the skyline but if we're on a if
it's aw if we're on a globe then I
shouldn't be able to see it cuz it
should be on the other side of the globe
and that that's all the logic they need
and of course you say well yes but it's
a really big club so you have to be
really far away from the thing to not be
able to see it if you're only a couple
of miles away you'll still be able to
see it but it doesn't matter all they
need is just that one little excuse and
in that gap they can build this entire
fantasy interesting to see alright we'll
leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for being here and
Godspeed